(upbeat Motown music)
- [Gary] You know,
on the timing thing,
the Russian culture has some
fun sayings that we don't
have in America that
I always love to, to kind of
English-ize in my head.
My dad and mom and
grandma would always say,
"Man has a plan and God laughs."
And I love that because I think
that's a little bit with timing.
Right? I sit here every day
and try to figure things out.
And try to figure out people's
activities and cultures and
where's the market going
and how are people
going to adjust to it.
And then something happens.
Just real events.
Macro bad events.
Macro good events.
Some kid right now,
right this second, literally,
Carol is sitting in
a suburb of
London and literally
just this second as I film this,
not even when this airs,
not even when you watch it,
right now as I'm filming it
she invented the next thing that
is going to change the game.
Change my game.
Change, create a situation
where mobile devices
are going to be different
and just like changed it.
She just did it.
And so all the planning,
all the concepts,
all the strategy,
all the learning,
all the experience goes
out the window.
That's the market.
That's the timing of it.
That's why it's so important
and that's why it's so respected
and that's why
I respect it so much.
And most of all, that's why
I think it's practical and
that's really ultimately
going to be the thing
with me is that I feel I'm more
practical than most people.
That's why I think it's
practical to respond to
realities instead of
trying to guess them.
Because, boy, if I had to sit
here right now in New York City
and guess everything that
everybody's up to
that's gonna shift the
market that I play in,
the world that we live in,
I'd be crippled.
And so, way too many people,
way too many of you,
way too many of you
make decisions without
factoring in that the
game's gonna change
by the time you
execute your decision.
And that is where
you get caught.
And for me,
I play the reverse of that
and that's why I have respect
for timing and the slipperiness.
It's like catching
this oxygen, that it is.
And so for me, that's why it's
practical to respond quickly
instead of trying to
predict these things.
(upbeat Motown music)